après les océans lo ng ocean clean up
s'attaque au nettoyage des fleuves et
des rivières où flottent des millions de
tonnes de plastique
voici dix intercepteurs derrière le
bateau de 24 mètres lors une barrière
courbet qui piège les déchets et
détritus surtout du plastique sont
récupérés par un convoyeur replacer dans
de grandes bennes à ordures lors d'un
test en malaisie la barge a pu récupérer
jusqu'à 50 tonnes de déchets par jour
le système fonctionne à énergie solaire
et il est complètement autonome ocean
clés ne pas fabriquer quatre de ces
barges à un million de dollars chacune
et elles doivent être déployée
prochainement island au vietnam et en
république dominicaine au championnat
s'attaque ainsi à la source du problème
parce que 80% du plastique qui polluent
les océans et des vertes et par les
fleuves
[Musique]